youtube is i don't know man where the
weird point yeah in youtube
i think it's dead
i think it is too it's dead not dead but
it's it's honestly it could never be
dead so i was going down my
timeline i was getting a bunch of
honestly interesting stuff i in like
five minutes i get
a clip of some weird parasite
snake
at the bottom of the ocean it's not a
snake but it's like you know some [ __ ]
like a bunch of teeth two clips later
it's this like dude who makes
mal hardware demos so he like is showing
this rfid scanner that you can order for
a couple hundred bucks and he's
demonstrating how he could
swipe an access code or even a hotel
room code and get into a door and all
this crazy stuff that used to be
the lore of youtube where you could go
oh i can go on here and i can look at
some crazy thing or watch all that crazy
yeah yeah now people do that on tick
tock and everything is so truncated that
with fighting we get a ton of comments
where people go i don't give a [ __ ]
about fighting but i like hearing you
guys just kind of boil it down for me
and so i think it's just this change in
people where
we're kind of content not seeing the
whole thing yeah so yeah i think it
makes youtube weird
because
i think a lot of
youtube is sort of predicated on that
like people want to see the whole thing
and now i think that's where why mr
beast is at where he's at because he has
to do the most extreme things to get
people to go all right i'll give you 15
minutes yeah you know what i want to
stop seeing on my for you page
[ __ ] pimple popping videos
stop putting that [ __ ] on my feet i've
never once watched the whole thing i've
never even watched the pop it grosses me
out so [ __ ] much dude yeah so gross
no way you actually like those videos no
no oh my god i honestly wonder because
they all have a million likes
who the [ __ ] watches these you sick
[ __ ] this is like
sick
how do you not get that it's just
in it's a human it's an infection on a
human skin you're sick
[Laughter]
you are sick get help there's this one
where the guy pops the pimple in like
the first half a second so you cannot
yeah you cannot like skip it right so
i'm like scrolling down my feed and it's
like cooking videos cooking videos is
all my feed is now it's pimple popping
and cooking videos which is not a great
combination
by the way scrolling scrolling and you
know like the self-censorship people
have to do on tick tock to make your
video not get like repressed or taken
off
people just every single word you could
ever imagine you know yeah and so you
know somebody makes a sex jokes and that
sex joke and they have to spell it segs
yeah scwgs and i'm like that's so stupid
and then i scroll down i see paws just
spraying against a mirror and i'm like
how is this not more
like [ __ ] up than just reading the
word sex yeah i think it's uh
that's what's wrong with this country
that is everyone's interests
it's
the plus
it's segs and then pus yeah i think
that's what the tic toc algorithm is
really good at trying to figure out i
think the algorithm is really geared to
try to drag you into the
into the smut you'll be scrolling and
then they just
just throw a little something in your
in your ear like
like my my [ __ ] is all
weird you know
23rd century memes that don't make sense
i'll just be scrolling they'll be like a
cheeseburger with like i'm sexy back in
like
a four bit
it'd be like other random stuff and then
you know it'll just like be something so
randomly horny and i always feel like
it's just trying to be like
you want to mix it up yeah yeah it's
it's almost like the netflix you still
there
but with like a pornhub injection yeah
like imagine at the end of every like
every other netflix show they just
propagated a soft core yeah it's like
what time is it you feeling feeling
something a little different yeah they
know how to massage the right areas of
your brain it's like oh now you're
hungry yeah damn these
cooking videos i'm so hungry and then
it's like oh now you're horny yep how
about that oh geez yeah and then oh now
you're [ __ ] disgusted here's past
spraying against a mirror
and then a dog and then oh wait a cute
dog oh wait oh well now you're in love
with the dog yeah i love dogs now you
want to eat the dog
are you hungry
you hungry now you want to eat it
probably no no i don't want to eat it
here's a here's a video of a dog getting
kicked off a bridge
oh no no now you're scared no poor dog
rinse repeat back to the food yeah now
you want to [ __ ] the dog
again
i'm sure it's on there man i'm sure
there's animal abuse and all kinds of
[ __ ] on there there's just you know it's
just maybe it's the algorithm like
saying get off you know
no you've been watching cooking videos
for 30 minutes and then it's like here's
a pimple yeah like oh gross and it's
like yeah exactly
what are you doing
nah i think it's your job
no i think it's like a it's like
supposed to zap you and then you get
back into the cycle you're like oh i
need a hundred more tick tocks to wash
that out of my face yeah or my brain ben
actually sent me this really
uh
pretty well-designed article it was very
like web
like
like not opengl but it was it was sick
like you would scroll and
it would have like
you know tick tock scroll by like little
sound bites and they basically created a
bunch of bots and all the bots were
their accounts were age 13 to 15.
and they
had a set experiment where the bots
would engage certain behaviors so like
one of them
on the first day
it liked one tick tock and it observed
one tech talk that was um about weed and
then on day two it liked or i don't even
think it liked it i think it just
observed it
on day two it observed another tick tock
about a marijuana cake and then they
laid out this grid of like
the first frame of all the tick tocks it
had seen and then it highlighted all the
ones that ended up being like really
dark like
how to take psychedelics what
psychedelics to take what psychedelics
do to you how to grow them it's just you
know just the rabbit hole going deeper
and deeper and it ended up being like 67
of like a thousand tick tocks or
something
so it was just like off those two it
just
progressively at a very accelerated rate
just started ramming drug content wow
that down like easy the bots like feed
it's not surprising but i feel like tick
tock does it more aggressively than
anyone else yeah like we're so focused
on facebook
and uh i don't know like
youtube
doing that stuff like that's what the
social network was about right yeah it's
those two primarily yeah and just like
the recommendation engine but tick tocks
is on steroids
yeah this [ __ ] is crazy it did it with
sex as well and sex you mean sex yeah
yeah that didn't even matter because
then it just kind of
spiraled into
bdsm and and like you know really sort
of advanced
like advanced sexual like interests you
know like stuff that you may may
discover over time but i think the the
main crux of the article was like dude
these accounts are registered as 13 to
15 years old yeah how is there no
regulation oh wait the accounts were 13
to 15. yeah and still they were
promoting drug use yeah sex sex
and then something that they kind of
sidebarred was like you know some of
these some of these tick tocks were like
yo i grow mushrooms and if you want to
buy mushrooms but you can't get them
like click the link in my bio and then
this person is like offering ways to get
it
and if you couple that with kids like
knowing how to use crypto and stuff
you know it's not to say that kids don't
try drugs but [ __ ] oh man like
i don't think it was that easy you know
back in the day maybe depending on who
you are but then similarly you know only
fans creators are like obviously there
like promoting what they do and there's
nothing inherently wrong with that but
the idea that a 13 year old could just
be fed basically two or two out of every
three tick tocks is like something
really sort of
beyond what they really understand it's
[ __ ] nuts
but then it has positives you know like
i look at this comedian like nemesh
patel he
he
has like a tick tock where someone asked
him like oh how's tick tock change your
life and he was like
you know i uh a couple months ago i
didn't have any dates booked and now i
have like a full tour booked and uh gets
done great things for me so it there is
like definitely positivity to using it
but
at what cost i don't know i think it's
murdering everything else
how do you feel about youtube are you
inspired these days making a lot more
[ __ ] than i used to yeah
just because i just wanted to see what
happened you know
like yes just by posting regularly like
three two three times a week
i mean it hasn't really affected
anything like i'm making more money now
but like my subscribers haven't gone up
my views have kind of stayed the same
so i kind of was thinking like that's
the way to compete with
tick tock and with everything it's just
like post as much as you can or the
other way is like
treat it like jontron does where it's
like you spend a lot on one video so
that
yeah it's guaranteed people will you
know
be excited to watch it but yeah i mean i
experimented the same thing this past
month with uploading a lot and it kind
of it just murdered me so now i have no
idea what to do no but i think it goes
through like these that as well it's
like it's such a such a toss-up like you
don't know you could keep that up and
then your next month could be insane i
also feel that there's this interesting
thing with tick tock where
you see them all like all the kids that
blew up on it
there is a ceiling
you know that's why charlie's like and
the you know demilios are trying to go
to
traditional tv and music and other stuff
it's this weird [ __ ] where
they get big and then they want to
transfer over to youtube but then they
know everyone's on tick tock and it just
becomes like
i think there's just going to be a power
vacuum where someone's going to create
something where everyone goes yes this
is what we want and
i think youtube tick tock i think all of
it will just get
like flattened in the process it just
feels like that that is coming like i
don't know what it is but maybe it's
global warming
you